what led you down this route of trying
to make geometry Primal like underived
elements of reality
just mostly the thought that I could
understand I could I could see how
a geometrical representation could in
principle more or less directly
correspond to the structure of the world
that the world the physical world sorry
that the physical world could literally
have a geometrical structure
and I don't understand how the physical
world could literally have an algebraic
structure
so I I'd like to get along as much as I
can with geometry this word geometry is
interesting when I was in university I
always thought of geometry as I forgot
the exact name but I took some course
where it's almost like euclidean
geometry or it is euclidean geometry and
there was inversions I had to do some
problem with inversions this is all I
remember what is that called analytic
geometries there's some word for it like
planar geometry something like that I
mean I I'm yeah I'm not exactly sure
okay well anyway it's with what you
construct with lines and circles and
then there's differential geometry and
to me I see that as extremely algebraic
firstly it's also contingent on the real
numbers
differential geometry is basically what
you use when the geometrical structure
changes from place to place so in
euclidean Geometry you have all these
nice symmetries right the the the the
the structure of euclidean space
is the same everywhere
so there's kind of translational
symmetries and it's the same in all
directions so they're rotational
symmetries right it's actually the same
even under expansions and contractions
which is really unusual that's not true
in in in even a space of uniform
curvature so it has all these nice
symmetries but you could be living in a
world where the geometry just doesn't
have these nice symmetries and then the
geometrical structure changes from place
to place and then you have to use
differential geometry which just means
that you you characterize the geometry
local in some little region and then in
the next one and then in the next one
with all these little overlapping maps
that cover the different regions and and
you don't have a constraint that the
geometry looks the same
in all the regions now none of that
suggests using numbers
and it doesn't you don't need to use
numbers I mean you numbers tend to get
in again with you when you introduce
coordinates but they're coordinate free
characterizations
of all of this of all of this geometry
so you don't need and as I said if the
space is curved then no coordinate
systems will be particularly great right
um the nice thing about uh of spaces of
constant curvature and especially zero
curvature is that there are these nice
coordinate systems like Cartesian
coordinates so forgive me because it's
been a while since I've been in
University the way that I recall it is
that you define a smooth structure by
saying that so and so is infinitely
differentiable to Define
differentiability you have to say that
it goes from the reels to the reels I'm
sure you have some chart in between it's
like RN but somehow you have a curve
that's R to the m so R to the manifold
and then from the manifold down to a
chart so you require the reels here then
the reels on the chart and then you say
it's differentiable based on
differentiability in the reels I don't
know if that's correct please forgive me
if I'm incorrect I don't know that's the
normal way it's presented I mean what
you say said is perfectly accurate is
the way it's taught that you throw in
functions
from the space to the reels or the r to
the end
uh as part of the story yeah and and
then you talk you you you talk about
whether a function from RN to RN is
continuous and so on
um by appealing to the structure of the
real line that is the usual way it's
presented it doesn't have to be done
that way
and it should be obvious that there's
something quite artificial about it
because if I just have a space in front
of me
where's this function into the real
numbers coming from well it only it only
comes by somehow laying down coordinates
which could be done in infinitely many
different ways
and choosing some arbitrarily
um and what you would prefer from as a
pure as a calculational matter
what they're doing is fine because it's
easier to calculate with numbers
as a conceptual matter you're better off
avoiding
this use of numbers where you can
because they're only introduced in a
kind of artificial way
so yeah I mean your your memory of that
is perfectly correct but people people
teaching math are not
I mean especially unless you really go
deep into the foundations of mathematics
they're teaching you a tool
um and when you learn calculus and
Vector calculus and so on they're giving
you a tool for doing calculations and
grinding out answers that's a very
effective tool
um what what
happens if you're a philosopher like me
is that
it's not so interesting learning how to
use the tool I mean when I when I was
doing my PhD in history and philosophy
of science because I was specializing in
physics I did was had to do graduate
level work in physics
and I took one course and I remember you
know perfectly fine horse Physics course
interesting for my purposes interesting
things were said on day one
the first day
because it was on the first day that the
the professor was trying to set up
what are we doing
and then the rest of the course which
was like how to use greens functions to
solve differential equations okay it
didn't matter to me I mean it just it
made no difference for my interests now
if you actually if I needed to get
numbers if I needed to actually grind
numbers out I really needed to
understand all the rest of that of
course but that's not what I do right
I'm more interested in well why am I
using numbers anyway
you know not how exactly do I use them
or or how do I solve these equations
right my only rarely one once or twice
in my life if I had to actually solve an
equation to make progress
um
and what I do can you give me an
instance of them of the one or two times
where you had to use an equation oh yeah
I mean I mean I I mean I remember this
very when my very first book which is
quantum non-locality and relativity
there's a
there's a a chapter which is about
part of it is about trying to mimic
non-locality violations of Bell's
inequality through a certain trick which
involves having uh particles or objects
that you're observing that just don't
show up that disappear that never show
up in the data okay and if you're very
clever you can use
this
Gap in the data
so that the data that does actually get
recorded will look like it violates
valve's inequality even though nothing
non-local has happened
um and then there was a question that
arose which is well how efficient can
you be that is you you want to say I can
rule out this kind of trick if my
detectors
are have a certain efficiency right if
my detectors are 100 efficient if every
time I throw a particle at a detector it
registers
then I can't use this trick because the
trick really depends upon there being
these missing data
uh but then you say okay well how how
exactly how much
Efficiency do I need before I can rule
out this loophole
and to answer that I had to actually
solve a differential equation which I
offhand I didn't quite know how to solve
I could write it down
um
and I I was actually I was in Croatia
off the peach I had a big yellow legal
pad and I had a little hand calculator
and I swear to God I sat there and and
numerically simulated an integral by
hand with this calculator uh until I got
it close enough to say hey that looks
like pi over four
and then once I saw that I said oh yeah
it is pi over four then I could work out
right how it goes how long ago was that
oh that was gosh 30 years ago okay so
this is before Wolfram Alpha oh yeah oh
yeah this is this is before you were
born you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy